I'm making this claim against Herbalife
for a year and a half now and with the
exception of your first announcement and
FTC making their announcement all we
really saw was a pop in the stock even
after you brought out the people from
the company and their sort of sob
stories even after we saw China which we
thought would be a big aha moment you
really didn't get the stock drop that
you had hoped for
why do you know our goal as I said from
the beginning of time was not to get a
stock price drop our goal was to
catalyze regulatory interest in the
company and what's happened since are
after they actually the day after our
tour day out of our China presentation
is the Federal Trade Commission launched
a formal investigation of the company
the Department of Justice has launched a
criminal investigation of company the
FBI has launched a criminal
investigation the company various state
attorneys general has launched
investigations of the company so I think
we've been successful in catalyzing the
regulatory interest what's different
about tomorrow is this is not something
we've talked about before you know we
have our early presentation we made some
references to nutrition clubs but we
didn't really understand how they worked
so we spent the last year with
undercover investigators in many
multiple countries and in the United
States participating and trying to
figure out and ultimately figuring out
how nutrition clubs work and we have you
know hundreds of hours of recorded
conversations now this is stuff we've
not yet turned over to the government we
will be doing that promptly after the
presentation but this is new material
and when I'll say about nutrition clubs
if you go you know just read the last
few conference call transcripts the
whole growth of the company in the last
several years the emphasis has been on
what they call daily methods of
consumption in which the nutrition Club
is the biggest driver and the nutrition
Club is a total and complete fraud we
will be showing that tomorrow